protesters mocked the idea of a
so-called National Guard but for
Israel's far-right security minister
it's no joke itamar bengavir says the
new force will tackle what he calls
nationalist crime and terrorism
I think
we need to strengthen the existing force
of the police which is lack of 2 000
police officers for uh in general for
regularly policing duties and it will be
blessed if they will add those this
budget and the the police officers which
they want to
to do in this program
three months of protests and Strikes
against Plans to give politicians more
say in the appointment of Judges
eventually forced prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu to pause the judicial
overhaul
the price extracted by Ben gevir to
agree to the pause was the promise to
create his National Guard opposition
politicians say it'll be nothing more
than a private Army of thugs the
priorities of this government are
ridiculous and Despicable it existed
three months and the only thing that
keeps it busy is crushing democracy and
promoting extreme fantasies of
delusional people
netanyahu's cabinet has agreed to cut
budgets from all other Ministries to
provide the estimated 278 million
dollars needed to fund the new Force
it's an indication of how Reliant
Benjamin Netanyahu is on support from
the far right that plans for this
so-called National Guard have suddenly
been Advanced the prime minister's
office says the exact powers of this new
force will be discussed in a committee
made up of all Israel's security
agencies leave 90 days to make their
recommendations
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera West Jerusalem